a convoy of contractors and journalists
made its way into palmer the mozambican
government wants the world to see this
we were taken under military escort with
armed soldiers accompanying us
the president insists the militants have
all been cleared from here
but his forces were caught off guard and
almost certainly they'll need to be
international cooperation if mozambique
is to defeat this terrorism
the residents are returning slowly
they're amongst the poorest in the
country
and there are worries that some may have
been seduced to join the armed group
through poverty and desperation there
are suspicions the terrorists managed to
infiltrate the town
and may have had inside help is now
swarming with soldiers
it's a militarized zone but the
president's accepted he can't win
by military means alone and has promised
many more jobs for the young
one contractor with us was aghast seeing
the damage
done to his business you see what's
happened
outside you see you think the truck is
okay i opened and everything's bent
inside it's going to be tough to restore
confidence here
i finish with mozambique i'll try to
sell my company
i cannot stay i've got family i need to
take care of all them
there's an ongoing investigation into
not only how the militants managed to
overrun the town
but how they went on to lay siege to
this hotel
which was packed with nearly 200 people
amongst them
expats foreign workers and villagers
who'd taken refuge here
the amaroola lodge has been ransacked
now by looters
who seem to have gone into every room
turning it upside down
and stripping it of valuables for zavika
karadi who had workmates trapped here
it's a difficult journey just imagine
when i was speaking with my guy
how they was feeling to stay and
to know around them it's all these
guys want to kill them with the
terrorists closing in on them
some came up with a plan to break out
it was only a few miles towards the
beach and possible safety and the
option was because they couldn't leave
by helicopter that they'd try and hatch
a plan to leave by
vehicle 17 a convoy of 17
or so vehicles that were gonna move
out and rush to safety but almost
as soon as they exited the gates of the
amarilla
they were ambushed with a number of the
militants hiding in the bush outside
and shooting specifically at the drivers
only seven of the vehicles made it
amongst the dead was britain fillmore
his body was recovered from one of the
abandoned vehicles
and when the villagers returned they
made a horrifying discovery
under a tree opposite the amaroola lodge
they say a massacre took place
they led us to where they insist they
found a dozen bodies
now buried but all foreigners
all of the bodies were laid out under
the tree
with the hands tied behind their backs
and their heads had been cut off
there's still little known about the
armed group who carried out these
atrocities and caused such
destruction here and where in this
desperately poor area
they are getting their funding from no
no
we don't know the reason why they're
fighting or who the enemy is
right now they need to ensure it's
secure enough to rebuild
and first priority is restoring the
phone network
okay huge difference for people to find
their loved ones
that are missing and have been able to
communicate this we think it will
contribute a lot to
to help stabilize the current situation
yes and ease the pain
over the next few days southern african
leaders will gather in mozambique
to hammer out plans to combat this
terror threat amid growing alarm at the
insurgency spreading
alex crawford sky news in palmer
mozambique